hey crazies there are three big
misconceptions about the universe that
people still don't get let's set the
record straight
this episode was supported by brilliant
org okay so I have briefly mentioned
some of these in previous videos there's
a whole playlist on cosmology if you
want to check that out but I'm [ __ ]
sometimes so I could believe you might
have missed them one how much bigger
will I be at 80 years old after you
account for the expansion of the
universe exactly the same size well
maybe not exactly the same size
most people are shorter when they're
older because of biological changes but
the expansion of space has exactly zero
effect on your size are you saying the
universe isn't expanding inside us oh it
is it's just not strong enough to
stretch you think of it like this
imagine you and the love of your life
are holding hands but you're each
standing on your own conveyor belts that
move in opposite directions you know
because the universe is always against
you anyway
the belts try to pull you apart but
they're not strong enough to overcome
the grip you have on each other's hands
you stay together as the belts move
beneath you the force from your hands
hold you together the same kind of thing
happens with space except in three
dimensions space stretches through you
while you stay the same size because
there are forces between your atoms and
molecules that hold you together they're
strong enough to overcome the expansion
of space solar systems galaxies and even
clusters of galaxies are held together
by gravity so they don't expand either
however the expansion of space is
uniform throughout the universe but
gravity gets weaker with distance at a
sufficiently large distance the
expansion winds and can start spreading
things out that happens between super
clusters of galaxies that's clusters of
clusters of galaxies the universe is big
enough that one point of light in this
image is a super cluster of galaxies
space is big really big
- why does it look like we're the center
of the universe because we are the
center of the observable universe we
can't see the whole entire universe
because light doesn't travel fast
the universe might be infinite it might
be finite
but either way light hasn't had enough
time to travel all the way across it so
this is all we get to see of it
that's the observable universe that's
how far light could have possibly
traveled since the Big Bang and this is
the light that's traveled the farthest
the Cosmic Microwave Background the
observable universe and the entire
universe are not the same thing
unfortunately some people call both of
these things the universe and it causes
a lot of confusion anyway since light
takes the same amount of time to travel
from every direction we see the same
distance in every direction which makes
us look like the center of the universe
even though we aren't three how could a
3d universe be flat it's not it's not
actually flat you know how words can
have multiple meanings when we say the
universe is flat we're not using that
word in an ordinary way these shapes are
just visual representations of math flat
just means zero curvature the universe
doesn't actually look like any of these
shapes honestly we should probably stop
using them but people like pictures if
you want to understand anything
involving general relativity then
remember this the easiest way to see
curvature is by drawing parallel lines
for example if you draw parallel lines
on a flat piece of paper those lines
will stay parallel across the entire
piece of paper if we live in a flat
universe and the data suggests that we
do then parallel lines in our universe
should do the same thing let's say there
are two space ships each ship plots out
a course they think will be parallel to
the other ships course if the universe
is flat those courses will stay parallel
as the ships travel no matter how far
they go they'll always be the same
distance apart what other option is
there Oh
oh I'm glad you asked on a sphere like
the earth two parallel lines come closer
together over time if the spaceships are
flying in a positive curvature universe
then their paths will come closer
together over time
on a saddle two parallel lines spread
apart over time if the spaceships are
flying in a negative curvature universe
then their paths will spread apart over
time
planes spheres and saddles are just
lower dimensional examples of curvature
it's the curvature that matters not the
shape so I hope that clears things up as
usual if you have any questions please
ask in the comments thanks for liking
and sharing this video a special thanks
goes out to patreon patrons like Daniel
Barr those regular support keeps the
lights on and the cloning machine
working don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy watching YouTube videos is
fun but knowing physics like I know it
takes loads of practice if that sounds
interesting to you then check out
brilliant org brilliant is a
problem-solving website designed to
train you to think like a scientist on a
wide variety of topics oh look here's a
course on astronomy with a unit on
cosmology let's try out the quiz the
shape of the universe
hmm these shapes ligado a familiar which
sketch below shows where objects moving
directly away from each other would
eventually come back together again I
bet you could answer that one after
watching this video if you find yourself
struggling that's okay brilliant even
has hints and solutions to get you into
that critical frame of mind it's a great
way to practice without too much
pressure
brilliant org was nice enough to sponsor
this video and crazy enough to offer you
would discount the first 200 people that
visit brilliant org slash science asylum
will get 20% off an annual premium
subscription it's a really good offer if
you're into this sort of thing I wanted
to take a few seconds to thank the demon
for diligently and accurately helping me
answer questions in the comments there
are just too many for me to answer by
myself thank you and thanks to everyone
for watching
[Music]